Tengo un amigo Canadiense que hace años se
fue de vacaciones a España. Cuando volvió,
lo primero que me dijo fue “¡Fonseca, no
me puedo creer que tu país esté en crisis!
Todas las ciudades están limpias, calles
bien pavimentadas, aeropuertos, trenes de
alta velocidad… ¡Vamos, que Madrid no tiene
nada que envidiarle a Zurich!”
¿Y sabéis que es lo más gracioso? ¡Que tenía razón!
A primera vista, España parece un país rico.
Sin embargo, detrás de esa fachada, hay un
país en crisis, con unos índices de paro
nachovidalianos y que está pasando por la
mayor crisis política de su historia.
Destituyeron a Mariano Rajoy como presidente
del gobierno español
Con el apoyo opositor, el Congreso aprobó
una moción de censura en su contra por corrupción.
A no ser que viváis en una cueva, ya sabréis
que España acaba de cambiar de gobierno ¡Pero
no por unas elecciones sino por una moción
de censura! ¿Y qué es una moción de censura,
os preguntaréis? Pues, básicamente, que
la mayoría de los Diputados del Parlamento
propone un gobierno distinto. Como sabéis,
en España, al igual que en muchos otros países,
los ciudadanos no votamos al Presidente. Votamos
a los diputados, es decir, al poder legislativo,
y estos a su vez eligen al Líder del ejecutivo.
Dicho de otra forma, que el parlamento pone
al Presidente del Gobierno pero también lo
puede quitar. Y en este caso, casi todos los
partidos políticos de España se han puesto
de acuerdo para poner fin a la administración
conservadora del Partido Popular, con Rajoy
a la cabeza.
Pensadlo, hablamos bien de uno de los movimientos
políticos más complicados de la historia.
El nuevo Presidente del Gobierno, el socialista
Pedro Sánchez, ha tenido que poner de acuerdo
a políticos de izquierdas, de derechas, pro
independencia catalana y anti independencia
catalana. Todos ellos tenían una sola cosa
en común: no estaban dispuestos a mantener
al Gobierno de Rajoy.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué Rajoy tiene
tantísimos haters? Por supuesto que está
los escándalos de corrupción… pero, en
honor a la verdad, ninguno de esos casos afectaba
personalmente al Presidente. Y el Partido
socialista, que es quien toma el gobierno,
tampoco está limpio, precisamente.
Mientras tanto, Mariano Rajoy asegura que
su gobierno ha sacado a España de la crisis.
De hecho, estas fueron sus palabras de despedida.
“Ha sido un honor dejar España mejor que
como me la encontré” –Mariano Rajoy
Y por eso, la pregunta que nos hacemos hoy
es ¿Es esto cierto? ¿De verdad está España
mejor que hace 7 años? Es cierto que España
está creciendo económicamente. Pero sigue
siendo el segundo país con más desempleo
de Europa y el avance está siendo mucho más
lento que en otros países como Irlanda, por
ejemplo.
Así que ¿Hasta qué punto podemos
decir que Rajoy ha sacado a España de la
crisis? Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes…
… antes de que sigáis viendo este vídeo,
tengo que hacer un PARÉNTESIS. Este tema
es especialmente emocional para mí. Mucho
más que Cataluña o cualquier otra cosa.
Veréis, hace muchos años que NO voto al
Partido Popular. No les voté en las últimas
elecciones y no creo que lo haga en las próximas.
Ahora bien, Mariano Rajoy fue mi primer jefe.
Mi primer trabajo a tiempo completo fue como
creativo en su Equipo de Campaña, en la sede
de Calle Génova. Eso significa, aunque no
esté de acuerdo con muchas de las cosas que
ha hecho Rajoy, tengo muchos y muy buenos
recuerdos de esa época.
Dicho esto… ahora sí que vamos a ver un
poco de historia.
LOS HOMBRES DE NEGRO
En el año 2002 se crea la EUROZONA. De repente,
España, Alemania, Francia y muchos otros
países tienen la misma moneda: el EURO
y
los mismos tipos de interés: los marca el
Banco Central Europeo. Todo esto tiene muchísimas
ventajas. Al tener la misma divisa, un banco
alemán puede prestar dinero a una empresa
española en las mismas condiciones en las
que se lo prestaría a una empresa alemana.
Pero también tiene un riesgo. Si España
quiebra, ese banco alemán que tiene deuda
española quiebra también. Es decir, que
los problemas de un país de la eurozona se
contagian a los otros países. Y precisamente
para evitar este riesgo, el Euro tiene unas
normas.
Una de ellas es que ninguno país
miembro tener un déficit superior al 3%.
Es decir, que no pueden gastar más de lo
que ingresan.
Sin embargo, vamos a avanzar rápido en la
historia. Con la crisis financiera internacional,
un montón de países Europeos se hunden económicamente.
Y España es uno de los que peor lo pasa.
De repente, la tasa de desempleo supera el
20%. Y eso significa que el Gobierno recauda
menos impuestos ¿Recordáis esos trenes de
alta velocidad y esos aeropuertos internacionales
que había en España? Pues resulta que hay
que seguirlos pagando. Y eso explica lo siguiente.
España, Grecia e Irlanda tuvieron los mayores
déficit fiscales de toda la Unión Europea
en 2012
Para que os hagáis una idea, si el compromiso
de déficit era del 3%, España estaba en
el 10%. Y eso significa que nadie se atrevía
a prestar dinero a este país. A fin de cuentas,
si gastan un 10% más de lo que ingresan ¿Cómo
van a poder devolver un préstamo? Y como
ya sabéis los veteranos seguidores de VisualPolitik,
cuando los inversores no se fían de un país,
piden intereses más altos.
Veréis, en la zona Euro, tenemos un indicador
que mide el riesgo de impago de un país.
Si veis este vídeo desde España seguro que
ya lo conocéis. Se llama la PRIMA DE RIESGO.
Y funciona de la siguiente forma. Damos por
sentado que el bono más fiable, y por tanto,
con el interés más bajo, es el alemán.
Así comparamos el interés que dan los bonos
de los demás países con los de Alemania
y el númerito que nos sale es la Prima de
Riesgo.
Pues para que os hagáis una idea, en el año
2010, la deuda española tenía una prima
de 50 puntos. Un año más tarde, estaba ya
por los 250.
Los bonos españoles están en riesgo y el
contagio para inminente
Y aquí es cuando entran en escena los famosos
“hombres de negro” que es el nombre con
el que los periodistas llamaban a los funcionarios
del Banco Central Europeo que exigían a los
países miembros de la Eurozona que cumplieran
con sus compromisos fiscales. Es decir, que
fueran más austeros en el gasto.
Por ejemplo, estos hombres de negro fueron
muy estrictos con Irlanda. Y en otros países
como Italia, podríamos decir que colocaron
a un presidente del gobierno cuyo trabajo
era enderezar las cuentas públicas.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué pasó en España?
¿Qué hicieron estos hombres de negro en
España? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
Y creedme, es muy distinto de lo que contaron
la mayoría de los medios de comunicación.
EL HOMBRE TRANQUILO
El 20 de noviembre de 2011, el Partido Popular
arrasa en las elecciones. Mariano Rajoy se
convierte en el líder político con más
capital político de toda Europa, sólo superado
por Victor Orban en Hungría. El Partido Popular
o, como se le conoce por sus siglas, el PP,
tenía el 53% de los escaños del Congreso
y estaba en casi todos los gobiernos autonómicos.
Prácticamente, Rajoy podía cambiar el nombre
de España y llamarla MARIANOLANDIA.
¿Y qué prometió Rajoy en la campaña electoral?
Pues básicamente, Rajoy le dijo al Banco
Central Europeo “Chavales, no os preocupéis
que yo puedo controlar el déficit. Voy a
bajar los impuestos y hacer un montón de
reformas para que puedan surgir nuevas empresas
en España. Estas empresas crean riqueza,
contratan a gente y como ganamos más dinero,
empezaremos a recaudar más”. Básicamente,
toda la campaña del Rajoy se centraba en
la idea de bajar impuestos para que España
fuera algo así como el Silicon Valley
de Europa.
De hecho, para mejorar la estampa, el PP sacó
un vídeo publicitario donde explicaban todo
este programa económico. Vídeo que, por
cierto, estuvo escrito, dirigido y dibujado
por este menda que veis aquí. Tal cual como
lo oís.
¿Cómo haremos las cosas de otra manera?
El Gobierno debe establecer un marco en el
que las empresas puedan ser competitivas.
Si aliviamos nuestra presión fiscal y modernizamos
nuestro modelo impositivo, por ejemplo, haciendo
que PYMES y autónomos no tengan que pagar
el IVA hasta que no hayan cobrado las facturas,
conseguiremos que tengan una mayor liquidez.
Sin embargo, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
una cosa es lo que se dice en campaña electoral
y otra lo que se hace una vez se llega al
gobierno.
“Este gobierno se ve obligado a hacer una
subida temporal de determinados tipos de impuestos”
En los primeros meses de Rajoy, el Gobierno
subió todos los impuestos posibles y esas
reformas tan maravillosas se quedaron bonitas
palabras. Desde luego, a los votantes, entre
los que me incluyo, no nos hizo ninguna gracia.
Pero eso no es lo peor. Lo peor es que esos
inversores internacionales que estaban expectantes
por ver lo que haría Rajoy… perdieron toda
la confianza de la noche a la mañana.
La economía española está en una crisis
enorme después de la degradación de su crédito.
Básicamente, el bono de deuda español pasó
a considerarse un bono basura. Esa prima de
riesgo de la que os hablaba antes superó
la satánica cifra de los 666 puntos y muchos
bancos españoles estaban al borde de la quiebra.
Nadie en el mercado estaba dispuesto a comprar
deuda española. Y los que lo hacían, exigían
unos intereses nachovidalianos. España estaba
a punto de quebrar. Y eso significa que nadie
podría pagar los sueldos de los funcionarios
ni los hospitales ni los colegios. Había
llegado el momento de los hombres de negro.
España acepta un rescate de Europa para los
bancos en apuros
¿Y en qué consistía este rescate? Pues
básicamente, Europa prestaba dinero a precio
de amigo para que los bancos españoles no
quebraran. A cambio, exigía que
el Gobierno hiciera recortes de gasto.
Y aquí es donde llega el gran pulso de Mariano
Rajoy. Lo que bien podría llamarse la “RAJOYOMICS”.
Básicamente, Mariano Rajoy se cruzó de brazos
y dijo “mirad señores del Banco Central
Europeo ¿Veis estos tres deditos? Pues podéis
leer entre líneas”.
La teoría de Rajoy era que, tarde o temprano,
el Banco Central Europeo terminaría comprando
los bonos de deuda de España sin apenas pedir
un tipo de interés alto. Con ese dinero,
España podía seguir como estaba sin tener
que hacer reformas ¿Y por qué iba a comprar
deuda el Banco Central Europeo? Pues muy sencillo.
España es la 4º economía más grande de
Europa. Y nadie la va a dejar caer.
Y así es como pasaron los meses. El paro
continuaba creciendo. La prima de riesgo seguía
creciendo. La economía seguía cayendo. Y
el Gobierno del PP, lejos de hacer reformas
para que se crearan empresas, hacía todo
lo contrario ¿Queréis un ejemplo? Os doy
un ejemplo. El anterior presidente del gobierno,
Jose Luís Rodríguez Zapatero, que era de
centro izquierda, aprobó una ley para liberalizar
muchos servicios profesionales como los taxistas.
Pues bien, una de las primeras cosas que hizo
Rajoy fue dar marcha atrás en esta liberalización
y permitir que los taxistas sigan estando
protegidos por el Gobierno. Gracias a eso,
empresas como UBER o AirBNB apenas se han
podido implantar en España.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Funcionó este pulso?
¿Terminó la Unión Europea pasando por el
aro? Y la respuesta es… SÍ.
El BCE está listo para hacer lo que sea necesario
para preservar el Euro. Y, creedme, será
suficiente.
SUPER MARIO AL RESCATE
Durante meses, el presidente del Banco Central
Europeo, Mario Draghi, decía que no iba a
ceder al chantaje de España. Básicamente,
Rajoy exigía que Europa imprimiera más euros
con los que comprar deuda española. En otras
palabras, que los países ricos como Alemania
o Finlandia le regalaran dinero a España
sin ningún coste político. En fin, que no
parece un trato muy justo ¿Verdad? Sin embargo…
en este caso, Rajoy tenía razón. España
era demasiado grande como para dejarla caer.
El BCE estaría listo para comprar bonos débiles
de Italia y España
Para que os hagáis una idea, el 25% de la
deuda española actualmente está en manos
del Banco Central Europeo. Y esas palabras
de Mario Draghi diciendo que haría lo que
fuera por rescatar el euro fueron algo así
como un conjuro mágico. De un día para otro,
la prima de riesgo española empezó a caer.
De repente, los inversores volvían a comprar
bonos de deuda porque sabían que tenían
el respaldo del BCE. Y así es como España
se ha podido estar endeudando como si no existiera
mañana. Para que os hagáis una idea, este
país debe más del 100% de su Producto Interior
Bruto.
Mientras tanto, el resto de países de Europa
han seguido creciendo. Desde el año 2012
hasta hoy, Alemania se ha convertido en la
mayor potencia exportadora del mundo. La economía
de Estados Unidos ha vuelto a crecer y a crear
empleo. Y China ha pasado de ser la fábrica
del mundo a ser un nuevo mercado donde vender
productos. En otras palabras, que TODOS los
países europeos están creciendo. Y, lógicamente,
eso también incluye a Grecia, Italia y, por
supuesto España. Sin embargo, para Mariano
Rajoy, cualquier buena noticia era suficiente
para poderse colgar una medalla.
Rajoy: "España ha superado la crisis en tiempo
récord"
Estamos ya en el año 2015, año en el que
vuelve a haber elecciones. Y el Gobierno decide
celebrar la salida de la crisis con una bajada
de impuestos en campaña electoral ¿Y a que
no adivináis que pasó tan sólo un año
después de que Rajoy volviera a ganar las
elecciones? ¡Exacto!
Rajoy vuelve a subir los impuestos
En 2017 el nuevo Gobierno tendrá que recortar
al menos 15.000 millones el déficit
Como os podéis imaginar, esto de subir o
bajar impuestos dependiendo de si hay o no
hay elecciones no es precisamente la mejor
política para atraer empresas. Si a eso le
sumamos la burocracia, que sigue exactamente
igual que antes de Rajoy y todos los problemas
territoriales, es fácil entender porque España
sigue teniendo un 16% de paro. Mientras otros
países como Estonia o Irlanda, que también
tuvieron recesiones brutales, están mejor
ahora mucho mejor que hace 10 años, España
apenas ha cambiado.
Por supuesto que esta no es la única razón
por la que ha ganado la moción de censura
contra Mariano Rajoy. Podríamos hablar de
la corrupción y de muchas otras cosas que
habréis visto en otros medios de comunicación.
Pero, personalmente, no creo que este Gobierno
se pueda colgar ninguna medalla en gestión
económica.
En cualquier caso, ahora es vuestro turno
¿Qué nota le pondríais a la presidencia
de Mariano Rajoy? ¿Pensáis que España ha
dejado atrás la crisis económica? Podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y antes de despedirme, tengo que daros las
gracias a los que nos habéis apoyado en Patreon.
Hemos logrado nuestro primer objetivo en menos
de una semana. Y en unos días publicaremos
el primer vídeo que ha sido posible gracias
a vuestra colaboración. Muchas gracias y
como siempre, suscribíos a VisualPolitik
si no lo habéis hecho ya. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.